hey guys this is a super cult production
of congratulations
[Music]
well
we're wearing a hoodie oh [ __ ] he did it
to him and it's [ __ ] summer but it's
gonna be fall isn't it and it's gonna
get it's gonna creep up on you isn't it
right so what you gotta do is
go to chrisleya.com and get this
[ __ ]
just be ready
just as we're peeking in the fall right
just as we're opening up
j uh that j oh it just got me
just as we're opening the door to fall
peeking through the brushes
and there's fall right and you're the
first one with that [ __ ] oh god damn
it periwinkle
that's what i call it though god damn it
periwinkle life rips hoodie it's [ __ ]
ridiculous
and uh so yeah dude
so order it chrisalia.com god damn it
you can get the shorts too ah [ __ ]
god damn it you can get the shirt too
it's just all periwinkle it's it's
unreal but whatever dude you know we got
that and we got the oops button selling
like [ __ ] hotcakes and you know it's
crystalia.com
but we're here man and we're smelling
like cologne and i gotta i gotta admit
it i smell like cologne and i didn't
mean to but before we even get into that
i will be in dallas dallas
it's actually grand prairie texas but
august 26th that's close to dallas
dallas i will be at the texas trust cu
theater
too many words in there
uh the dallas texas trust cu ampa
[ __ ]
theater of the people too many words but
we'll be there um august 26th get your
tickets now
limited amount of tickets left limited
amount of tickets left the next day we
will be flying to wichita kansas to play
the orpheum theater now the thing about
that is why would we fly the day after
we fly
well
my tour booker decided to
route it
incorrectly
they routed it with a flight after a
flight even though i told them
please only driving after i fly into one
spot i want to drive drive and then fly
back home he didn't do it
wichita turns out he's five and a half
hours away of a drive to grand prairie
texas
and chris told him specifically
anything under four hours is doable so
now we are flying to wichita after that
we are flying to wichita after that
and he's pissed
and it and it's all good
oh great can't hear myself
and we are flying after
and we did it and the tour manager
absolutely messed it up and i know he
listens to the podcast too so if you're
listening
you made it worse
and it's all good but you made it worse
i'm going to be tired
you made it worse
um so gonna go to wichita we got the
tickets on sale there's a limited amount
of tickets left in wichita we are not
adding another show it's
limited and then we will fly home that's
too many flats that's how many flats too
many won but it's still too much it's
stressful
isn't it
then september 9th we will be in atlanta
georgia
limited many tickets left in italy
only on that third tier the first two
tiers are absolutely full
[Music]
limited amount
and then we're going to go right to
washington dc you know that's a flight
isn't it now we told what did we say
from atlanta to washington dc is it a
flight yes it's a no that's a flight in
it
now what did we say we flying we drive
we drive we fly we didn't do that this
time either that's two for two that is
zero percent of getting the job done
then september 23rd we are going to
stockton california and then
oakland he got one right
he got one right then we were gonna we
are going to fly to stockton and then
drive to oakland for the next day and
then fly home he got it right
he got one right finally he learned his
lesson
and then we were flying october 7 to
peoria illinois and then driving a
rockford illinois he got another one
right didn't he
and then he pretty much got it right the
rest of the tour boston
albany you could drive to there boss in
denver colorado i'll be out there go to
chrisley.com we got the [ __ ] new
cities coming and i just booked some new
ones i see your comments
i see your comments coming in full force
about hey when you're coming to new york
hey when you're coming to chicago hey
when you're coming to vancouver it's
coming
it's coming and there will be a limited
edition
so yeah dude and you'll be [ __ ] he'll
be [ __ ] high pressed to see me in
that periwinkle shit's in the fall
though dude so um yeah dude
that was entirely too long of an intro
but it's all good my babies and i and i
hope see daisy i smell like cologne is
it my fault no it's not did i hug a guy
with cologne yes i did is it all good
yes am i worried that it's gonna be
smelling like perfume and kristen's
gonna have questions yes dude but it's
okay cause it's obviously drakkar noir
the worst kind a perfume or whatever the
[ __ ] it's called
cologne dracar noir you know the [ __ ]
syllables in that god damn it you got to
be so armenian to be wearing drug card
noir
so armenian or so [ __ ] russian to be
wearing drug carne noir
a few spritzes
hey before we go out dog a few a few
spritzes dog
right on my adam's apple dog right there
a few spritzes dawg a8 get my a get my
bottom half too right hey get my bottom
half too right just in guess i get lucky
no seriously
hey watch where you're touching dog i
don't touch your face um so uh
uh yeah armenians love smelling good
artificially and also love telling you
about their [ __ ] boundaries
physically um
hey spray it hey not there bro hey hey i
wouldn't come to your house and spray
you there would i
um so yeah i do it but i do i hug a [ __ ]
i see a dude at start i went to
starbucks back of a cow's mouth does it
how does it taste terrible how does it
taste zero to ten how does it taste
really bad the only thing worth getting
at starbucks four shots over ice because
they can't really [ __ ] it up do they
[ __ ] it up yes they kind of [ __ ] it up
do i still get it yes because i need the
caffeine and cause it's not so far ah
yes i do i get it and i drink it do i
drink all of it no why because it's so
bad yes so i only drink half of it it's
fine the ice melts too quickly because
it's not
big enough and it's all good
okay now i come home the starbucks is
somewhere nowhere to be found i wish i
had on my desk but it's not here is it
okay yes does it make me remedy yes but
it's all right
because i'm chilling
and we breathe through it right my
babies we absolutely breathe through it
we deal with emotions here's what we do
um
so yeah so i got to starbucks and i see
all of a sudden a dude and he's standing
in the light and i realized wow first of
all i think handsome dude and then i
think i know this dude and then i think
how do i know this dude and then
immediately i think that's how i know
this dude
and i knew the dude and then he goes
what's been going on and i say hey
what's up dude we clap hands we [ __ ]
hug boom that's when i notice
a waft of drachar noir
and we don't like it but it's all good
but that's life
sometimes you hug a russian dude and he
gets drakkar noir spread all over your
neck and that's life
you gotta turn and then when he says
goodbye
you hopefully hug him in the same place
so it's only that one spot that smells
like it but that's life he goes for the
other cheek and then hugs you and then
on the both sides yeah you smell like
drug car noir
so as you go back to your car
you smell like rock 101
that's life
yeah and then you go back in your car
later and then all you do is smell
[ __ ] goddamn dry car noir
that's live you roll the windows down
and then you hear the clicking sound
because the wheel on the back left tire
is absolutely cracked and every rotation
you [ __ ] make the wheel go you hear
click click and you're so [ __ ] mad
cause either you're hearing click click
and you're reminded how [ __ ] shitty
your wheel is or the windows are up and
you smell draconia and that's life
but whatever dude my babies would keep
it nice we deal with emotions here dude
and we're rip-roaring in our periwinkle
shits dude i can't wait to get on the
[ __ ] road man and just absolutely be
crushing it on stage dude can't wait man
bringing the whole family with me
bringing calvin bringing kristen it's
going to be so ill dude it's going to be
so ill adult half-life
i mentioned [ __ ] goddamn attack on
titan as a throwaway the other day on my
podcast and [ __ ] the comments in
no not crystallia an attack on titan oh
my god the casual reference attack on
titan dude is you really know what japan
may does he really know attack on time
does he really know does dalia just
going to mention attack on titan and not
talk about attack on titan dude i know
about attack on titan because i've seen
almost all the [ __ ] episodes of
attack on titan because dude one day i
was in [ __ ] texas with my
ex-girlfriend and we turned it on
because she had [ __ ]
roku and that was the only [ __ ] that
came up and it looked creepy and i
played it and we watched it until the
[ __ ] where's fell off to avoid
her family we love him but you know how
it is with in-laws
you know how it is dude
that's life you watch japanimation
[Music]
to [ __ ] not deal with your in-laws
and that's life
but whatever wow i'm annoying [ __ ] but
it's all good dude
um remember i was talking about garbage
comedians on the [ __ ] patreon episode
last time and now i'm talking about
[ __ ] now because how annoying they
are now i'm being so goddamn annoying
dude singing that's life frank sinatra
at the top of my lungs all tone deaf and
talking about periwinkle shits ah sir
annoying so um
but anyway dude
uh
yeah dude i do a watch attack on titan
and i saw attack on titan and i watched
attack on titan until it got really
extremely convoluted and bad and but
it's great i love attack on titan i
[ __ ] loved it
um
and then also i'm wearing all white
today well what do you do it's before oh
what do you do it's all before labor day
oh well what'd he do though okay
do you hear because i'm wearing all
white what the [ __ ]
what'd you hear that
blast.com are you serious what the [ __ ]
is reporting
well sometimes media does tell the truth
crazy does he really no come on he can't
believe me no he's wearing all white
but he drinks so much coffee whatever he
spills he didn't spill me oh my god
that's [ __ ] insane but it's really
really all right but then he takes his
car in today what about when he got out
and [ __ ] brushed the wheel up against
it didn't get the black on his calves no
he didn't do it
seriously oh really how do you know it's
not that he's one of the periwinkle
shits yeah he is
under the underneath oh why not what
about the lint the perimeter no it
doesn't have it on dude it's completely
white at all times i'm wearing all day
that's what i hear when i walk by
[Laughter]
[ __ ] dude
all white dude and all white pants dude
like i'm going to cp diddy [ __ ] it man
i'm in the hamptons practically
firing in all syllables
and cylinders today but yeah dude we uh
yeah so i went yes so i am i'm wearing
all white so whoopsie daisy that's how
we did it and i did go to take my car in
because there is a clicking sound on my
[ __ ] wheel i always got car problems
that's just how it's going to be i'm
always just i'm going to be the guy with
car problems that's going to be my thing
it's okay everyone has their things some
people die of cancer and some people
just have a car problems their whole
life and that's going to be my thing
right some people battle with weight i
don't you know i have a lot of weight on
my shoulders but that's all muscle and
dick area but dude yeah okay so that's
gonna be my thing
um
oh we have a good time we have a good
time here on this uh congratulations
podcast
and uh
there was something i wanted to [ __ ]
talk about up front i can't [ __ ]
remember what it is the um
we were chilling and we made a [ __ ]
for dude i was out or something i can't
remember where i was and i and i was
like uh
where are they going i think i could get
a coffee or something or did i have a
show you know i think no i had a show
and uh kristen would and cal he sleeps
like late dude the [ __ ] kid dude i
love him and he won't even he's like
he's such a dalia he's just like no
there's more [ __ ] to do i can't go to
bed yet i have to play with my peppa
pigs
what are you talking about go to bed i
have to watch shapes on youtube i have
to watch shapes
he'll just be like shapes
and i'll turn on shapes ah that on
he talks like a [ __ ] old vietnamese
man nah the other one oh really yeah
that shapes
okay i look over he's squatting in some
[ __ ] high grass
the shapes
i want to watch that one dada the shapes
so i turn it on yeah that's the one look
he has a pyramid
and then a triangle is different right
you know that is called the dart i
didn't know that was the shay that's
what they called dart literally that's
what it's called dart
and um
so i'm watching the shapes and then i
[ __ ] leave to go to the
show and then i come and then kristin's
like guess what made a fort for cow it's
just gonna be family chilling me and
calvin in the fort and i look dude i'm
like all right send me a pic dude she
doesn't send me a really good pick to
see i come home after the show i'm like
is calvin's still up dude he was still
up it was like 10 p.m i came home dude
she [ __ ] blew up the air mattress put
a whole bunch of [ __ ] bed sheets all
over this rope that she tied together
and hooked it onto the tv across the
room to the back wall behind the couch
and put a [ __ ] lamp
in the middle holding the [ __ ] sheets
up to make a [ __ ] apex like an
a-frame with the sheets dude and i had
no idea where the lamp even [ __ ] came
from dude
and kyle was just chilling in it eating
ice cream just [ __ ] scooping it up
and literally putting it on his mouth
not even opening his mouth he would just
put it on his mouth and then the ice
cream would fall on his belly dude like
what the [ __ ] is going on here and it
was so ill dude and i came i said can i
come in and he goes no
that's not for you and i did anyway
because it's my [ __ ] house dude
and i went in and i [ __ ] we had a
good time dude and he was laughing and
he hit my nose a little bit i thought i
thought he re-broke it it's all good
don't tell my doctor because if the
surgery didn't work i don't want that to
be my fault
but um
so we watched a little bit of stuff we
watched lilo and stitch which honestly
sucks but he loves it uh not for me lilo
and stitch is not for me and uh
yeah but you know it's just it's like
it's it's old [ __ ] you gotta watch the
new cartoons
so um we built a fort and it's
bro we did it [ __ ] saturday when are
we recording this what is it monday bro
and it's still up
the fort's still up and the air mattress
has a hole in it we have to keep
refilling it and it's so loud when we do
dude but when he [ __ ] hits that we
you we refill it it goes
right and then when you when you and
then the other button on the thing is a
um a release that lets the air out and
it goes
it sounds like you know what it sounds
like one of those [ __ ] um hydraulics
where the porn girls use when they just
sit there in the stirrups and the
robotic uh
[ __ ] thing just goes
i don't know who watches that porn not
me but i see it on the [ __ ] on the
thumbnails dude
and
um like a sybian you know whatever and
uh
why do i know what it is
so uh so uh yeah and then he hits the
button calvin hits the button and it
just goes
and he laughs
like
[ __ ] hell dude when he hits that
button
that's the [ __ ] and then i laugh dude
what can i say i love being a dad what
can i say what could he say dude what
could he say i don't know he's working
we're not white what the [ __ ] is going
on something believers weren't all right
give me what apparently i think i saw a
[ __ ] lint on it linda's white get
that so now he's going to wind and kind
of lint on the things which is more
white it's unbelievable
seriously when you hear that the media
that donald truth what the [ __ ] that's
insane um
yeah
whatever what are you gonna do
oh i gotta announce the winners of this
[ __ ]
this is what i gotta do this is the only
thing i gotta do this episode so the
other day we put uh as a month ago we
said anybody who buys anything for the
month of may
gets uh a chance to enter
uh a raffle to win this black and white
life rips
oh the varsity jacket for [ __ ] sake
he did it to him so uh these are the
winners
uh
marcus boyd i'm gonna actually just do
their instagram handles this is what i'm
gonna do marky 206
kyle
weil k-y-l-e w-i-l-l-e uh karl lagers
karl agers i don't know uh martin b 192
uh this guy's
instagram is marcos antonio.gastelum
ah sir well i mean just change it right
change change change your brain who you
are uh and then patty the mick she's a
[ __ ] italian a gangster and then sami
izzy a fish sammy sam dot is the
official it's insecure is he official
and um
two don't want to be announced and i
don't think i did that okay good that's
cool whatever dude you got the jacket
dude yes dude so that's the thing maybe
we'll do another one and now we're gonna
guess what we're gonna make them this
was such a [ __ ] hit we're gonna make
them in color so we can get them in
color now dude you can get them on
christmas.com whatever dude uh i can't
believe i saw uh
on a [ __ ]
uh
i don't know what's go do is crazy craig
robinson was doing the comedy zone i
think in uh what do you call it uh north
carolina and somebody pulled a gun out
dude this is what happened i know that
you guys might not know specifically
what happened so i'm gonna tell you i
know what happened because i know
what happened because i'm in the [ __ ]
[ __ ] and i'm in the shits right and i
know the [ __ ] no no craig and i know the
people right craig by the way couldn't
be a nicer dude to have some pull a gun
on craig is the most hilarious [ __ ]
because he's the most chill person alive
you pull on a gun on craig robinson i
feel like he would just be like what
song you want to hear right like he is
unbelievably chill
so
um
the guy came in to go to craig's early
show
and he thought he had tickets for a
different person
okay now the guy's packing heat nobody
knew it he had a piece on him nobody
knew it right he had his [ __ ] biscuit
with him but nobody knew it all right he
had the burner tucked in between but
nobody [ __ ] knew it right so he's
sitting there just like a [ __ ] baker
on the move right biscuit talked into
the belt okay
and he said hey i'm here to see whatever
comedian he thought he was there to see
not craig robinson they say sorry you
got tickets for the wrong show or maybe
you wanted to see craig robertson but
these are the wrong tickets you bought
you don't have tickets to see craig
robinson and he said okay well can i get
the right tickets and the guy said well
unfortunately this show is sold out but
why don't we try to make room for you in
the next show later the late show and
the guy says oh really well no if i'm
not getting in i guess the show's
canceled now nobody's getting in
everyone's going home and he pulled out
the [ __ ] biscuit and walked in the
room dude and then craig canceled the
whole weekend dude
that guy
that sucks that he did that dude if
you're gonna bring a heater here's the
thing dude if you're gonna bring the
[ __ ] burner
if you're gonna bring the [ __ ] nine
pound if you're gonna bring it
don't flash it around like it's a rolex
be using that [ __ ] okay at least fire it
in the air like a [ __ ] old west guy
like that's a bit some bit [ __ ] oh i
can't get tickets to the show that i'm
going anywhere then everyone's going
home how about that i'll do my own
comedy show
so that's what happened dude america is
absolutely crazy man
america is absolutely [ __ ] crazy
i don't know what's going on man ever
since [ __ ] uh chris rock got slapped
you know it's like a [ __ ] war zone so
cool i'm gonna have security on my [ __ ]
it's all good
i mean how many guns are gonna be in my
[ __ ] dollar show for real though
because of how [ __ ] texas is it is
i'm not against guns at all but you know
it's like don't don't be waving them
around at a comedy show don't
like dude that's
insane uh comedians man
what [ __ ] weird people huh r.i.p to
jack knight that was a great he was he
was great man he was in so much [ __ ] he
had everything going for him and uh
and he uh
you know i knew him not very well but i
knew him uh very in passing and um
seemed like a nice dude and was a great
comedian
and uh good for the good for comedy and
in a lot of stuff man i mean that guy he
had a lot to live for and apparently he
was just too much for him
um
poor [ __ ] man poor poor guy but uh rest
in peace to jack knight we lost another
one and uh that's brutal
uh heart goes out to his family and his
friends
texted a few of them and let them know
um but uh yeah
sad [ __ ]
um
let's look at this now to get right back
into some comedy which is so
disrespectful but also respectful you
know what i'm talking about
here we go
come on
[Music]
well tracy morgan just doesn't give a
[ __ ] dude
oh that's how i gotta be
[Music]
oh that's so good dude he doesn't give a
[ __ ] god damn it does he want a shower
cap what the [ __ ] is that a hat like a
camo hat dude wow
dude just singing without a care in the
[ __ ] world man
god damn that's awesome i gotta be like
that when i how old is tracy morgan how
old is he look it up dude i gotta be
[ __ ] by the time i'm that age i gotta
be out loud singing in the airport
that's me dude that's life
dude and somebody could just say your
flight's cancelled and i just go that's
life and i'm just killing it dude
53 that's not even that old dude wow
that's like some 70 [ __ ] year old
[ __ ]
i gotta [ __ ] get there dude i've got
11 years
i know i'm the ripe age of [ __ ] 42. i
get it dude
god man
somebody was talking so loud on
speakerphone the other day they walked
into a cafe i was sitting in the cafe
and this dude was talking to speaker
phone walks into the cafe orders on
speakerphone and somebody on the [ __ ]
speakerphone whoever they were talking
to says well yeah but did you know that
yada yada about somebody and then i said
oh really real loud and everyone looked
at me but that's because that
conversation must have been for all of
us
it was on speaker and you were in a
public place
we were at a [ __ ] cafe so if he's on
speaker then i'm involved in this
conversation
you think in 11 years i won't be [ __ ]
belting out [ __ ] at a gate
at [ __ ] delta you think i won't you
think i won't say i won't
you're talking to the guy who wore all
white
yeah dude i think it's [ __ ] fantastic
when people stand up for what they
believe in in that way right
i think it's great
too many people are just singing in the
[ __ ] uh
lenses of their camera and putting them
on instagram that's some bit [ __ ] dude
oh you're really a singer then
oh you're really a singer then go out to
the [ __ ] gate of delta and absolutely
belt it out
you raise me up
higher than a [ __ ] mountain
do it at panera bread even though it
should just be panera because panera
means bread so basically the place is
called bread bread
you raise me up at relax the back go go
do it
higher than i could even [ __ ] be
you raise me up at susie cakes or cvs
[ __ ] go do it how does he keep coming
up with [ __ ] stores it's because i
[ __ ] just did the ones at laurel
county in ventura boulevard
dude that's what's all around the laurel
county and ventura boulevard they got to
relax the back dude wow
relax the back dude the worst title for
a [ __ ] company
it's still around how does it like chris
webber [ __ ] didn't some basketball
player make it
relax the back dude that's the [ __ ]
relax the bank that's the worst [ __ ]
that's so
who made it
no basketball player you don't know
some basketball player has a stake in
that like it's [ __ ] uh
dun dun
hi sharks i'm chris webber you're tired
of your back not being off you're tired
you're back being all stressed uh what
do they sell like lazy boys or recliners
or some [ __ ]
kobe dietrich that's a basketball player
i knew it he knew it dude he's a [ __ ]
encyclopedia britannica what the [ __ ] he
knew it i'm hot as [ __ ]
this room is [ __ ] three feet by three
feet
um so yeah dude but uh what was i saying
i don't even remember what i was saying
but i love it
i love it i love it we gotta get to that
[ __ ] singing part of life you gotta
get to that part dude that's why i say
life rips because once you realize life
reps no matter what happens right like
say you eat too much sugar and you get
[ __ ] cancer at 65 right and you
realize oh [ __ ] it's pancreatic i'm
donezo
because that's one of the worst ones
i'm done so
you gotta know life rips by then you
gotta know that [ __ ]
that's why life rips because there's the
negative [ __ ]
and the pendulum swings right
some people before they die they realize
the best [ __ ] of their lives
they realize what life's about
not me i don't know what life's about i
try to figure it out but you know it's
really hard what is like i don't like
those big ass questions though like what
what's life about you know like some
richard attenborough [ __ ]
everyone wants to know what the age-old
question anytime anyone says to me
anything about any age-old question i'm
i don't want to know any age-old
question the answer it's age old means
nobody figured out before me nobody's
gonna figure it out
um but yeah
dude have you guys come across this
[ __ ] it's like a reddit
it's all over reddit i don't i i've
literally
only been on any reddit because of stuff
that ivan gets rid of sends me
i don't really understand it you can
like vote stuff up and stuff down wow it
sounds so old but um
dude this thing he was showing me is
[ __ ] hilarious
it's a tinder thing right where they
just show tinder
conversations
like before they date
or something like that
yeah and uh
like this is the tinder reddit page i
guess a community for discussing the
online dating app tinder sharing
conversations reviewing profiles and
more
um
so this is so people are so weird dude
like people are so
[ __ ] weird
that i i don't you know how like people
are like well the world's gone to hell
and everyone's like
at each other's throats i am actually
when i see [ __ ] like this i'm surprised
anyone is still alive
because
people
disagree on so much [ __ ] like when i see
[ __ ] like this this is the one
um
this is what the person says all right
all right i gotta i just gotta say you
are absolutely stunning
um
and then the person says you should know
i injured my foot on thursday so i can't
walk very far did you have a place in
mind
first of all just off to a [ __ ]
absolutely uh try this is a travesty
already like want to go out yeah broke
my foot can we go close
uh
oh okay so well i guess i'm not getting
laid but yeah yeah yeah let's go close
what's close to you
um so then the guy says ah damn sorry to
hear that i can take the train in i'm
from long island
so i really don't know the area
and then the person writes
i mean i can't even wow the person
writes
a potty mouth
i'm okay
and then
the okay so if this were me at that
point i'd be like i'd have to like scan
the conversation and be like what is the
potty mouth part
and this person then replies damn's a
potty word lol but i'm glad you're okay
and then the person writes back again
may you please not curse when you're
talking to me
thanks so mormon
dude to like what like why
like leave it alone hey hey guys leave
it alone right the most leave it alone
you should have left it alone already
way before like first of all the broken
foot thing i'm out dude this is tinder
right like dude i didn't even meet you
yet
how how amazing do you have to be
for me to even just
like this is just a profile you might be
a man for all i know
hey my foot broke do you have a place in
mind gotta come close already i'm like
okay this is already you're being
difficult sorry you broke your foot but
now i got to take the trainer from long
island
and then he said oh damn sorry to hear
that sean sympathy
and then she says a potty mouth hmm
smorman dude leave it alone why even say
potty mouth [ __ ] just ghost them from
there
and then the guy says damn's a potty
word but i'm glad you're okay
don't say that and then the other person
may you please not curse it's already
over
you bored
get hobbies
right
unbelievable this [ __ ] is unbelievable
unbelievable
it's unbelievable
somebody said ned flanders has entered
the chat
it's great
here we go another one
this is great dude these tinder shits
was this too harsh it says forgive my
ignorance but what's an odp
somebody says google it
and then somebody wrote i tried to start
a conversation by giving you the
opportunity to talk about something
you're presumably interested in
obviously i can [ __ ] google it
dude i know who this guy is this is a
guy i got a pizza from once uh at la
canada imports down
uh on foothill boulevard and uh alta
kenyatta because i got pizza for him and
he was doing it and he would always
[ __ ] get pulled put out the pizzas
and pizza was so good there and then one
time he turned around and he got a piece
of pizza from his wife and his wife says
it's hot dude and this makes well i'll
tell you this part at the end actually
and he said she says careful it's hot
and he turned out to round to me and
under his breath he said i know it's
[ __ ] hot dude that's this guy that's
this guy on tinder now and dude how much
sense does this make he was white and
older and his and his wife was asian and
younger oh makes too much sense man send
scale off the charts dude
come on guess what race older white guy
talking to a younger female asian course
i know it's [ __ ] hot
basically what he was saying is she
killed you oh you had a chance you know
what i mean like i'm not saying there
was a chance or whatever that's not me
saying that i'm just doing it for what
he probably that was the tone of the
[ __ ] thing right
basically called her charlie is all i'm
saying but i'm just and that's not me
saying that i'm just saying what this is
the tony ad but dude this is amazing
forgive my ignorance but what's an odp
google it i tried to start a
conversation by giving you a dude this
is john malkovich
do you know what i mean like so pinpoint
accurate with this verbiage i tried to
start a conversation by giving you the
opportunity to talk about something
you're presumably interested in
obviously i can [ __ ]
google it
dude this is basically a line from in
the line of fire
that's what [ __ ] the bad guy says to
clint eastwood and i'll do it while i'm
pissing on your grave
i'll [ __ ] say i'll [ __ ] laugh
about it when i'm pissing on your grave
and then john malkovich comes in over
the phone i tried to start a
conversation by giving you the
opportunity to talk about something
you're presumably interested in
obviously i can [ __ ]
google it
um
dude also such a robot this is just a b
this is honestly just ai dude this is ai
dating this is a robot trying to get his
[ __ ] bolts wet
this is an oh this is a this is a
[ __ ] robot trying to [ __ ] get his
get his [ __ ] uh
nuts and bolts just creamy dude hello i
would like my nuts and bolts creamy
forgive my ignorance
but what is an odp
google it
identifying [ __ ]
comments attitude
i try to start a conversation by giving
you the opportunity to talk about
something
you're
presumably interested in
obviously i can
[ __ ] google it
[Music]
moon walks out
and then [ __ ] i wonder why that [ __ ]
plays by tupac
over his speakers he just opens his
mouth
dude it just goes
and his mouth opens and it goes wonder
why they call you [ __ ] wonder why they
call you [ __ ] as he moonwalks away dude
wow these are so fun dude what the [ __ ]
is up with dating apps
here we go i hate dating apps so much it
says
since you shared your batman story i
once had dreams of being a powerpuff
girl and then the guy said so were you
made from sugar spice and everything
nice and then the girl just writes
no
and then she says and if that line ever
works for you you should question why
and then he says it's from the intro to
powerpuff girls it's not a pickup line
lol
[Laughter]
dude
unreal did she know it or not it's not a
[ __ ] line it's from the intro the
[ __ ] that you brought up
dude
turn the combo on his [ __ ] ass
that girl sitting on her [ __ ] right
now dude
it's from the [ __ ] you brought up
[Music]
oh my god dude unreal
one for the boys dude
[Music]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] men had it rough the
past five years but we back after that
message you brought it up
dude you brought up the powerpuff girls
oh you thought you knew more about girl
[ __ ] than i did well let me [ __ ] slam
it back to you and bring some up
undercover
and you don't even know about it and
then you get mad at me and dude let me
just chuck one down for the boys
[Music]
it's another one
my dogs are insults get the [ __ ] out of
here bud butters butters has a son i
never told you guys i won't talk about
it ever he has his son
dude one time for real better says his
son
but it says a son i'm not joking he has
two sons
i'm not joking my dog one time i was i
used to hang out with this girl and she
came over once and we were hanging out
watching tv at my apartment we had sex
and when we got done dude we looked over
and butters was stuck inside her dog
didn't know didn't know what the [ __ ]
dude butters wouldn't come out
you know that some the dogs have like
penises that have like grappling hooks
that they go in and then they [ __ ]
open up and then they can't get out to
ensure insemination it's very [ __ ]
gross but that's what happens and
butters was looking at me like what the
[ __ ] going on dude and sure enough
insemination happened and butters had
two sons and she gave one away and then
had another one and then and then her
[ __ ] ex-boyfriend took it and she
cried a lot on social media about it
what the [ __ ] is life but that's what
happened so butter sun is out there
somewhere
these reddit shits are amazing let's
look at another one
dude he slammed her to a [ __ ]
bolivian
dude wow
unbelievable dude the guy the boys are
back aren't they huh
after that
after that dude
boys are back
oh i just did that one okay i hate when
i just did that one this is good because
it clicks the checks the ones we did one
fire did that i had it to [ __ ] change
his name no one from one higher huh
uh he had reading as an interest in his
bio a common one okay
so the guy writes so you like reading i
see what's the last book you read and
the best book you
[Music]
read
and then somebody said oh oh
oh
so he had reading in his bio
and then
she says so you like reading i see
what's the last book you read and the
best book you read and then the guy
writes [ __ ] off
dude
oh dude and then she writes what why we
have reading as common interest i just
wanted to start a convo any any rights
[ __ ]
ciao
oh the boys are back
dude men had it rough for about eight
years and that's it thanks to this
italian speaking [ __ ] dude
[Music]
dude that's unreal what he did man oh
you thought we were gonna talk about
something you wanted to just because i
put it on my profile well [ __ ] you
got another thing and think coming
[Music]
oh dude chabitch slammed up dud up dub
duh dub let the boys be boys
unbelievable dude what a dick that guy
is you know
what a dick his name's tom that's
hilarious too and it's in and of itself
let's do another one dude these are too
fun we got to keep going wow god damn
dude this is fun i hope you're in your
car on a road trip and you just keep
[ __ ] driving you're like i hope this
podcast never ends because that's how i
feel this one says how do i respond
please job this is just a guy reaching
out damn if you wait
damn it
[Laughter]
dude
this is
t-a-t
l-y-n-n now granted that name is stupid
as [ __ ] okay but he says
damn if you were my teacher i'd be
tattling on all the other students just
to talk to you
and she writes back this is the best
are you [ __ ] stupid
it's taitlin [ __ ] idiot oh
[ __ ] dude
the dudes had a good run for about 14
minutes
women are back dude
unbelievable man
wow dude i still like well why is it
spelled tatlin
there should be an e in there
there should be an e in there you know
what dude she's actually wrong that
guy's not an idiot dude uh oh another
one for the [ __ ] boys she was
technical difficulty or technicality
whatever the [ __ ] you know
you know what i'm trying to say dude
disqualified
[ __ ] dude
god damn these ones are great
i did it checked it off all right now
this one check it off um
a headache from screaming at all and i
got to sign it i got signed it go home i
know about the bleed that's great is
this weird matched two weeks ago she's
nice
um sometimes i don't know who's who so i
guess this is
this is him so i heard of them they
sound cool they're that korean band yeah
spelled wrong but they're wrong there
but uh then they write yeah that's one
of the reasons why i matched with you
looking for a asian guy because i want
wagian babies okay so she's white
he writes whoa haha bit
early to talk about babies and then she
writes no not really i'm young but i def
see myself being a stay-at-home mom and
i love babies
they're gonna be on my mind and i'm
always going to be planning
to have one or four maybe five holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude
hey
you need to take a course on how to get
what you
want i mean this is absolutely insane
dude first of all in the beginning
it's racist
and then
also
absolutely not going to get what you
want even though that's the thing you're
talking about wanting okay
so sweetheart
and i don't mean to call you sweetheart
but
i am
don't be doing all that wow that's
actually
that person will be alone forever and
that's so sad um
this one's ironic it's called
sanjay
the so the girl writes hi
and then sanjay write oh wait no that's
too sanjay so hi and then she writes
i don't know who's who is this a girl
girl
no this is the guy i'm in jamaica for a
week what do i absolutely need to do
before i leave
and then they say something you're
interested in i guess
lol what am i to say
and then they say
i don't know i figured you'd have some
ideas because you live here or you could
just say you'll show me around
and then they say i'm not a tour guide
honey i work lol
and then he says what do you do for work
she says i'm a travel agent dude
oh
unreal dude
attempts at your tour guide
oh my god the [ __ ] absolutely rare
um
embossed die cut sl self [ __ ] slam
you're a tour guide
oh my god dude the foil embossed the die
cut the limited edition ultra rare
self slam
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
unbelievable bro
how do you get self puned so bad
got a headache tell my doctor it's
because you stuck [ __ ] a really
[ __ ] long long
[ __ ] things that aren't penises up my
nostril
i'd never allow that no penises up my
nostril
i get why this podcast is [ __ ] fire i
get why people listen to this you know
what dude i get why people listen to
this podcast they just want to relax
it's basically like going to relax the
back and getting the best recliner they
just want to chill have a good time they
want to let me do the heavy lifting on
the silly goose time and you just want
to [ __ ] take that road trip or be in
that cubicle and have to take [ __ ]
orders from [ __ ] people on phones
but have me in the background and talk
to you about [ __ ] you know silly
goose shits i get it
i used to not get it but i get it and
also these are the hard hitting issues
right
you got npr shits out there talking
about [ __ ]
you know like
who killed some woman because she was
trying to expose some [ __ ] uh
dignitary and [ __ ] in spain or malta and
[ __ ] now they're trying to get to the
bottom of it it's like why do you want
to hear all that i get it but like also
you got to hear about these tender
replies from crystallia
yeah i have a headache but it's all good
wow those are [ __ ] hysterical we got
to do that more for sure um
this is the deserved scale wow this
video is unavailable the first one good
job one fire
here's another one the second one
wcgw not sitting down properly what's
wcgw do i know that
oh what could go wrong not see is this a
reddit thing see
okay
not sitting down properly what could go
wrong
here we go
every
a hell yeah dude
wait
they made it did anyone get hit
oh wait what the [ __ ]
how did he even
what does his head was going to get hit
he sat down
oh he's not even there yet dude well
that was an optical illusion for a bit
dude this guy sat down and the pole this
is unreal
why was that pole so [ __ ] low to
begin with dude
this seems like a [ __ ] really bad
idea
i mean
paul is
i don't this is not his this doesn't
even look like his fault to me
do you guys understand what i'm saying
like why is it so low
oh because he's on the oh because he's
in the bout what they call the bow of
the boat because it's up it's up front
and oh that's great dude that's great
amazing dude i hope his cell phone got
all [ __ ] up it's his fault deserve it
scale i will say
it was pretty funny but then also
they shouldn't have the pole there dude
ah that one pisses me off that's a three
he didn't deserve that man to get all
wet with that [ __ ]
wow it's not often we have a low
deserved scale but that's good it's good
we need to know what the scale does we
need to see how the scale massages
itself here we go another one just
[ __ ] click that one
great already clicked it uh here we go
here's another one uh what could go
wrong if i annoy people on a busy
underground train
wow
you mean a subway
well the train's gonna stop right he's
gonna fall
this guy needs to get his ass kicked
[Music]
oh the build-up of this is
oh oh wow he touched the guy's face
oh
no way dude
oh my god dude
that is great
the guy is yelling some of the most
british [ __ ] i've ever heard in my life
i don't know what it is but it's so oh
moshe o'shea
jose oh it's a [ __ ] soccer team or
whatever football
joe
oh the other eve oh then that guy
deserves to get his [ __ ] head lopped
off honestly dude and he is standing
there in the [ __ ] subway they call it
an underground train i guess
[Music]
so drunk and i guess his girl's there
but we don't know but she's not doing
[ __ ] so honestly she deserves it too
so then the doors open
and the guy just talks
tosses him out he's so drunk that's
hilarious dude
look how he does it too
wow the timing of that dude
whoa
is that guy the pet rock
the timing of that was amazing and she's
like very funny very funny dude why
weren't you [ __ ] trying to calm him
down
you deserve it too deserve a scale off
the charts that one honestly wasn't
belly laugh but he totally deserved it
so that's an interesting one right
when it's not
terribly funny but he did absolutely
deserve it i would say that that's a
[ __ ] that's got to be high just
because of how much you deserved it dude
um oh he was so drunk after i hope he
got robbed afterwards no i'm kidding he
would have if it was los angeles but um
yeah i don't know i'd say that's an
eight
that's an eight that's gotta be an eight
unreal okay here's another one
uh
what could go wrong is great
use the force look this is win stupid
prizes okay now all right look
this is what i see
it's a it's a [ __ ]
there's two bottles of jugs here of
water hanging in front of the dude and
he's blindfolded so here's the number
one thing you know he's gonna get
smashed in the [ __ ] face okay and
then you've got george lucas behind him
i guess
here we go
here we go oh okay so okay so he's do so
if you're listening and you're not
watching this is what he does first he
does this like this so already he
deserves it at a top at a [ __ ] 10. to
do that
is so annoying
in any kind of like
this is probably like a [ __ ] honestly
a tick tock challenge okay so he's being
pissed [ __ ] already and it's [ __ ]
absolutely
uh
deserves a lot for doing that because he
thinks he's like in a [ __ ] what do
you call it um
what's that movie
uh
what was that movie american ninja
warrior okay
so here he goes
oh i know what he's gonna do he's gonna
push him and then move side to side
right why does he have a covered mask
over his eyes that's so dumb
yep one and two and bonk hit bonk right
in his [ __ ] nose wait a minute this
is set up
this is set up
this is set up dude you can't [ __ ]
get one by me
i sniffed it out you know why i know
it's set up
because the water bottles aren't [ __ ]
full
the water bottles aren't full
and look at his reaction bonk that's a
fake reaction that's a fake reaction
dude [ __ ] yeah dude he knows he knows
[ __ ] when he sniffs it but that's
good dude because you can't so how much
did you deserve it
you don't deserve the view but you got
the view all right dude fine you gotta
have a get rid of in one fire but you
didn't get me dude
maybe first look i might have thought
that um
not so much deserve a scale but it's
just so many bad things happening in a
row this one's what [ __ ] one fire
says
okay here we go
everything that could go wrong went
wrong
i love [ __ ] like this dude hold on let
me play it
guys taking a pizza out i tell
it fell on the thing oh these guys are
such bros
look he's got a mitten on
why is the oven over the [ __ ] washing
machine you know
well these guys deserve these guys dude
this is the way they're being they
deserve it so much
oh trying to get it out with a ladle oh
it fell on his face dude the cheese is
up wow you guys suck
[Laughter]
that took 25 minutes and it [ __ ]
that's what happened you know to heat
that pizza it took 25 minutes and that
was the combination
i love that [ __ ] i gotta gotta watch it
again
first of all the reaction of the of that
is
unreal dude
they scream
when the [ __ ] pizza falls
six inches and nothing happens
they just go oh
that's so funny in itself dude
the reaction bro
this is such a sleepover dude
wow that guy's so annoying
look what they're wearing too one guy's
dressed to the nines and one guy has no
shirt on him
all the onions and [ __ ] fall out
and then they put it on the dish and
they're fat
[Music]
nobody has ever dressed more euro trash
than these guys it's unbelievable i i
can't even believe it i cannot even
believe it
guys got tight
[ __ ] jean shorts on and a checkered
belt unfucking believable the other
guy's got no shirt on and an oven mitt
and the other guy's dressed like a
[ __ ] waiter off duty dude i can't
believe how euro trash i cannot believe
how your charge i [ __ ] did is
unbelievable they deserve that to happen
because of how euro trash they are that
is a [ __ ] 10 out of 10. if i was
there dude
if i was there
after that i would have left so hard for
so long i would have got up no matter
how exhausted i was from laughing i
would have beat the [ __ ] out all of them
dude that's what they deserve honestly
that's what they deserve
and they're for sure if if honestly if
they are not in argentina i will [ __ ]
cut my [ __ ] nuts off and eat them if
they're not in argentina that is the
most argentine no that is the most
salvadorian thing that has ever
that whole video is the most salvadorian
thing that has ever happened in the
world
so salvadorian dude
so [ __ ] salvadorian
god damn
gonna be in dallas get those tickets
they're running out atlanta and wichita
kansas uh i'm gonna be in uh
where else uh
peoria
uh
belco i'm doing denver the bellco
theater and i'm doing um
boston i'm gonna be at the wang ticket
to crystallia.com washington dc
uh so go and get that stuff
and uh if you don't
crystallia.com
and uh we keep it periwinkle all year
hey guys that's it for the youtube
episode this week uh if you want to
listen to the rest of the episode uh go
the raw the uncut the no
commercials no nothing
go to uh patreon.comcrystalia
and you can catch the rest of the
episode you can also if then you'll be a
part of our patreon and you can get all
the extra stuff that we do we do
something called review mode where we
drop that bi-weekly we have behind the
scenes footage we have a discord that we
chat on and we also have um
an extra episode of
congratulations uh every month
and uh if you go sign up now you get
access to all that past stuff and it's
just six bucks a month so uh
going oh and also you're supporting the
show and we appreciate it so patreon.com
thanks
[Music]
you